andy cohen is dropping bombshells fans
of the real housewives of new york city
will have not just one but two series
well life is surprising isn't it and the
bravo universe may never be the same i
got no news for you i got nothing
yeah i've
asked that question all the time but i i
really have nothing to say that's the
executive producer speaking with et last
month but now andy is laying out bravo's
plan for the franchise calling it a
tremendous opportunity for a rebirth of
the show here's the plan do you seem
very angry today
i mean
i'll do okay roni is getting the reboot
treatment with a brand new cast and the
network will launch a second series
featuring unforgettable cast members as
for assembling the relaunch andy tells
variety quote we're looking for a group
of women who are real friends and who
are of diverse backgrounds races and
religions we should all be evolving and
changing trying to be better people when
it comes to casting the second series
the watch what happens live host
confirms no casting decisions have been
made for now andy teases quote this is
the series where you're going to expect
to see fan favorites from the show's
great history the initiative follows
roni's low-rated 13th season this last
season of new york was a season that
wasn't people's favorites and for the
first time in real housewives history
the season wasn't followed by a reunion
special we didn't do the reunion i was
of course disappointed luanne here is
just one of many alumni contenders who
might hold an apple once again will roni
be coming back with you
[Music]
i've got to finish business i'll say
that
i think i would definitely yeah
absolutely because i really wouldn't
want last season to be the way i went
out just because it was a weird season
with covet and everything yep leah is
not exaggerating
oh my god let me take this
[ __ ] thing off
vance had a lot to say about how little
happened in the season is rhony in
repair mode or roni is in pause mode and
it will be in repair mode speaking with
et last year andy admitted the season
left a lot to be desired but remained
optimistic about the show's future all
right guys ready for pioneer
do you think there's a toilet here but
again it was shot during covid we went
to salem massachusetts it's probably a
place we wouldn't have gone in other
seasons we went to ramona's house
quite a lot yeah um and so you know
we're looking forward to next season and
just building on it and we're it's a fun
problem to have yes how do we make a
great show better
[Music]
you